SOURCES STILL USED IN THE
DOSSIER KEY POINT BUT REFUSE
TO NAME THEM.
ALSO TONIGHT CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS CONTINUE TO CALL
OUT THE BIAS IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS
MR. END THE WITCH-HUNT.
AND JOINING US NOW THAT
AFOREMENTIONED CONGRESSMAN
ANDY BIGES JOINING ME.
CONGRESSMAN, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
>> THANKS, DAVID.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> David: LET'S DIVE RIGHT
INTO THIS.
THE TIME LINE MATTERS HERE
IN THE TRAVEL TO TO COLLECT
THE INFORMATION TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
HAND IT OFF.
SO, WITH THE NEW SUBPOENA
AND SUBPOENA POWERS OF DEVON
NUNEZ, DO WE SEE CONNECTING
>> WELL, I THINK.
SO I MEAN CHAIRMAN NUNES IS
DOING A GREAT JOB BY ISSUING
THAT SUBPOENA AND DEMANDING
ANSWERS AND WE IN CONGRESS
HAVE TO KEEP RATCHETING THIS
UP BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE IS
BIAS.
WE KNOW THERE IS CONFLICT.
WE KNOW THAT WITH 10,000
EMAILS THAT GOT TAKEN AWAY
FROM THE TRUMP TRANSITION
PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THAT THOSE WEREN'T
REALLY GONE THROUGH.
IS JUST KIND OF SPUN OUTS OF
CONTROL.
AND IT'S WIDESPREAD AND IT'S
BROAD.
AND THIS MAY BE THE SCANDAL
OF OUR TIME, QUITE FRANKLY.
>> HOW DO YOU CONNECT THE
DOTS HERE?
OBVIOUSLY HAVE YOU THIS
COMPENDIUM OF INFORMATION.
THE EMAIL, THE TEXT MESSAGES
AND YOU PULL THIS ALL
TOGETHER.
IS THAT THE NEXT STEP?
SEE HOW THE FIRE STARTED.
>> THAT'S WHY CHAIRMAN
NUNES' SUBPOENAS ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON THERE.
WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE BACK
BEFORE CONGRESS TO ACTUALLY
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
AS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN, THEY
JUST KEEP DEFERRING AND
SAYING WELL, THE INSPECTOR
AFTER THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
WE NEED TO GET THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO HURRY UP WITH HIS
REPORT.
GIVE US THE INFORMATION,
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
>> ACCUSE TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
WE DON'T HEAR THAT ANYMORE.
BACK TO FOCUSED
INVESTIGATION SO WE CAN SEE
WHETHER THERE WAS COLLUSION.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW IS THE COLLUSION CAME
FROM THE DNC AND HILLARY
CLINTON.
WHAT WE ARE SEE SOMETHING
THAT THERE WERE ACTUALLY
PEOPLE AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF OUR GOVERNMENT TRYING TO
MANIPULATE THE ELECTION.
THAT'S WHAT IT APPEARS TO
DOTS.
WE NEED TO KEEP BRINGING
THESE PEOPLE.
IN AND WE HAVE TO PUT IT
TOGETHER.
AND RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
REFUSING TO ANSWER OUR
QUESTIONS.
WITH THE COVER THIS IS UNDER
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM FOR
US.
>> GOING BACK TO THE GENESIS
OF THIS.
IT BEGAN, OF COURSE THE
RUSSIANS WE KNOW THIS.
THEY TRIED TO INTERFERE WITH
ELECTIONS ALL AROUND THE
WORLD THAT SAID THIS BEGAN
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE LOOKING
INTO RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
THAT MEANS THAT ANY AND ALL
IN THE CAMPAIGN WHOEVER WERE
TOUCHED BY THIS SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED.
ARE WE GOING TO SEE CHAIRMAN
NUNEZ NOW LOOK INTO THIS,
NOT JUST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, THE
SANDERS CAMPAIGN.
ANY CAMPAIGN THAT WAS OUT
THERE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED OR ATTEMPTED TO BE
INFLUENCED BY THE RUSSIANS?
IN OTHER WORDS, IS THIS
GOING TO GO BACK TO WHAT IT
REALLY IS ABOUT?
>> WELL, RIGHT NOW, IT'S
KIND OF SPUN OUT OF CONTROL
AND FRANKLY, THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE HAS JURISDICTION
OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
CAMPAIGN WAS INVOLVED
SOMEHOW.
I MEAN, THIS IS REALLY SPUN
FAR BEYOND WHAT
AND WE HAVE TO BRING IT BACK
IN.
WE HAVE TO BE FOCUSED.
AND THE REAL QUESTION IS HOW
DID THE RUSSIANS IMPACT THE
ELECTION?
IF THEY DID LET'S FIND OUT
AND TAKE CARE OF THAT THE
REALITY IS IT'S BECOME SO
PARTISAN WITH MY FRIENDS
ACROSS THE AISLE THAT ISN'T
WHAT THEY ARE EVEN LOOKING
TO GET PRESIDENT TRUMP OUT
OF OFFICE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY WANT TO DELEGITIMIZE
AND THEY WANT TO STAIN
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSTEAD OF
SAYING LET'S SEE WHAT'S GONE
ON HERE WITH HOW DID
WELL, BECAUSE NOBODY IS
OVERSEEING HIM.
WELL, BECAUSE THERE IS NO
WE CAN GET BACK ON FOCUS ON
THE REAL QUESTION WHICH IS
AND WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD
IDEA.
BUT THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS
DOSSIER IS REALLY THE
SMOKING GUN AND WE HAVE TO
REALLY UNCOVER EVERYTHING WE
CAN ABOUT THAT.
>> David: A POINTED QUESTION
ON, THIS CONGRESSMAN,
SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
MORE.
PRIVILEGE, LEAKING THE
DOCUMENTS TO THE COLOMBIA
PROFESSOR AND HIS FRIEND,
AND THE FACT THAT IF HE DID
VIOLATE THE LAW, CAN HE BE
CHARGED.
DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD BE
LOOKED INTO AND, IF
POSSIBLE, CHARGED FOR
VIOLATING THE LAW?
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK HE SHOULD BE LOOKED
INTO.
I MEAN, HE TOOK INFORMATION
THAT HE HAD ACCESS TO,
UNIQUE ACCESS TO, MAY HAVE
BEEN PRIVILEGED INFORMATION,
COUNSEL, HE LEAKED IT TO HIS
BUDDY WHO WITH THE
INSTRUCTIONS GET IT INTO THE
MEDIA.
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
MONTHS AGO I STARTED SAYING
MR. MUELLER SHOULD NOT BE
ABOUT THAT.
WE KEEP BEING TOLD INSPECTOR
GENERAL IS LOOKING INTO
THAT.
AND WE DID GET COMMITMENTS
FROM DIRECTOR WRAY AND FROM
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
THEY WOULD REOPEN THAT IF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FELT
THAT THAT WAS A PROBLEM.
I THINK.
>> David: WE'LL WAIT FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
THEN CONGRESSMAN AND SEE
WHAT COMES OUT AND WHAT
ACTION IS TAKEN BY YOU AND